so we got chick versus gibble Stephen
ear Smith versus Joe Rogan we've got a
Dave door brick these two big things or
do you want to salt I don't care thank
you see you next week
go on oh thank you just want to do a
video
[Music]
you know you seen this design thing I
actually quite like you pretty good I
I'll be [__] on companies who try and do
modern-day content like dying but my
kids do you like violence you see mystic
Nine Inch Nails - each one of my kids
has ordered good the only thing I don't
like about cable is his name a Nissan
kid I wish I could have sat him down and
went come on we need some art but yeah
why - Aneesa rolls off the tongue
you need something parents can remember
vaguely racist but Fair Play
I need some give isn't a racial thing
it's just big no spin backwards on it
this is his name because he's from
another country all people mother
countries are funny names knows what his
real name is Ali I prefer that my real
name they're not all called Ali over
there Oh God it started when KS I was
riding gives dick in this video they use
ksi is almost like ooh Stephen a Smith
type character he's like that is exactly
what they should be doing the market
this fighting is gibble by his own
admission isn't that we all know that he
isn't on the same like level this Jake
in terms of numbers I'd love to see
cousin JJ is that like sports person
light them up and use them as the best
mate of JJ even though like you know
maybe that isn't strictly true but they
like good that's the way it goes
when the [__] is game I feel like give
me there's the a side that's [__] I
love the UK and all of that right and I
know what they're doing this is small
the Dro isn't small yeah and Jay Paul is
stone of you sure but Jay Paul C is he's
not this is Jake took the fight in hopes
then if / when he beat skin we can find
ksi he's dismissing give he's already
focusing on me and that's a bad bad
thing if you're Logan your kid brother
wants to take on the guy who beat you is
there a small but other things what if
he does it like you know her hair yeah
is it not that you want him to lose I
don't think that for one second Logan
would want him to lose but there'd be a
bit of him and he's already sort of said
if Jake wins he's I'm not the big
brother anymore basically yeah but then
if you look at Prince he go in Logan's
last video 20
that's all that super-good keep doing
the age thing I also got the C practice
and train car look up in the eye
nose cuz it's emotional isn't it isn't
it yeah it gets quite a mouth yeah I
dunno in your mind you in the body I try
to be more emotionally I could see Matt
I care about you yeah I'm not believin
Bruce yeah but they're both holding
their stomachs they both like holding
cool you know what I'm saying
I think I can feel it you have a much
stronger mental than I have so I don't
even think I need to save as much you
know and document it and also I'm very
fifty thousand dollars on you it's a lot
that's a lot of money imagine your
brother wins and then you win 50 grand
beat betting on it I mean that is a
great night so does he win 50 grand
or did he bet you've left Iran so that
means it's on the line so I don't know
what the odds are I mean I bet what kind
they pay him after that JJ fight because
I stupid money I think that must be
mental yo Steve imagine being able to
just bet 50 grand he's got a small party
bus he should drive around in a Rolls
Royce yeah yeah it's kind of sickening
really isn't it so especially there's
people starving in the world gosh yes oh
let's hope that never happens to you
Logan
yeah be careful passive aggressive fit
jealousy's nuclear motion sorry we went
to Mount Charleston it's the hard run up
your run very cold
it does look hard yeah it does look hard
I mean any run for me be difficult or
that looks really hard yeah absolutely
you get breathless going to the shops
I'm sure Shane Mosley seven-time world
champion three weight divisions I've
been addicted to the 2020 and after box
Hall of Fame a boxer first of all who
can speak post-career is incredible guys
it's really good yeah it's really good
to find someone who can dodge punches so
well they say this is the guy who's
putting Jake into shape isn't it this is
the x-factor in this fight absolutely
look how much bigger is than Jake that's
unbelievable I gotta be honest I don't
know how much you can achieve in a short
space of time Sugar Shane Mosley is the
real [__] deal if anyone can teach
Jade Paul what he needs to know to win
fights it's this guy obviously we
[__] believe in Vidal we've seen what
he can do but this is the x-factor we
don't know what kind of impact it's
gonna have I can only assume it's gonna
be good dog Jake Paul will be better for
going to a guy who really truly knows
bosses this could be a better fight than
we saw between Logan and JJ I think it
will be I think it's gonna be really
action path yeah
gibble when we've watched him
the last fight between swindler gibble
just does nothing but come right ahead
the whole time yeah
and obviously the technique is probably
going to be better in this fight I would
fully expect like it was over a year ago
now even more incredibly with his cardio
be even better yeah I think he'll be fit
he definitely looks to really fit
calmness heal but he'll be all over gee
that's the thing but I'm not detected is
lot of power
I think he's Oh like I'm he's got to hit
him punches and bunches glorious like
really where I'm down and constantly hit
him and be all over him so we're looking
for combinations yeah loads of
combinations that's gonna be great for
Gabe he's gonna try and wear Jake down
and tire him out because the pace is an
unreal pace yeah Jake is gonna have a
lot to handle the only thing is when you
keep coming forward like that and you're
throwing so many punches you are
available yeah
very available could be watching Jake
dougie Jake here looks like more
calculated to the to that the more calm
the more confidence for me Jake is the
more natural mover like he moves a bit
like this is a long time ago but you can
see even there he moves a bit more like
a poxy the main questions for me can
give or maintain the kind of peace that
he puts on people right for three minute
round six six rounds can Jay Khandala
who was better at avoiding being hit and
who hits harder like those are the sort
of main things I think Jake hits harder
and I think Jake's hard at would be hit
so if they both connect I would expect
Jake's to hurt a bit more with without
the head cards ten ounce gloves I know
it's cliche but it is true because he's
so the ultimate thing this is coming
down do for me is can't Jake handle that
the swarm the [__] tornado coming out
of him in Gabe without getting freaked
out about it and being calm about it the
doll made a really good point in that
breakdown and I think you mentioned it
means well it takes a certain level of
experience to handle Gabe when he's
coming at you it's just overwhelming and
you and how's Jake learned enough if he
has I think he wins because he is bigger
he might not have and in that case we're
gonna say the biggest upset in history
YouTube I mean Kimmel's Curry I was just
[__] take off then like he comes like
the guy then doesn't he he's got a clear
I know JJ's the guy but you know what I
mean like people will
hero worship him because people don't
like Jake like he could just sell
t-shirts with
yeah yeah the ultimate full stop on us
absolutely yeah absolutely so I'll call
way for the fight let us know who you
thinks gonna win in the comments so the
legend Joe Rogan has got himself into a
bit of a war of words with this guy
Steven Naismith is a loudmouth who gives
hot takes on ESPN ESPN signed a deal
with the UFC and now he's talking about
MMA he did a post fight recap with Joe
Rogan and he basically just [__] on
Donald Cerrone a Joe Rogan didn't very
much Stephen stunning I'm shocked and
disappointed I mean I don't think he
landed a single blow against Conor
McGregor it was like shadow fighting for
crying out loud
you know say one kick to the arms and
that was basically it the consensus was
the best way that he was gonna be able
to win was to keep distance and perhaps
use his wrestling so what Joe is trying
to do here is take it back to give
credit to Conor of course rather than
shipping on Donald he doesn't have it he
goes but Bushido that's the interesting
side of is Nick's obviously Joe's
working the interests of quite why he's
friends with all of these fight he's got
respect for them yeah where is Stephen a
there's no respect for what Donald
Cerrone that he said I'm disappointed
you're not his dad man no matter how
much experience you have you don't have
that experience
you're just ain't ready and that's how I
would look tonight cowboy Cerrone just
didn't look right and this is the pub
the problem with what you say no and he
also says that Donald Cerrone quit you
can be as ready as you like sometimes
you come up against a much better man on
the night Jozy aldo never beaten in ten
years Conor McGregor slept them and
threw in seconds yeah the same basically
happened to Donald Cerrone he's very
tough fighter but Conor McGregor has the
ability to blitz anyone finds a way so
the point is as he is he's discrediting
Cerrone
the truth of the matter is if Conor
McGregor lands like that on you and head
kicks the [__] out of you it doesn't
matter how ready you were before the I'm
sure he trained hard and when you're in
a position like he's in in a suit on TV
hold the microphone you have a
responsibility to the fighters to show
them a certain level of respect now on a
basketball game you can slay a player
like that and it maybe just flies yeah
you have a bad game well next week you
have a good well that's the interesting
because basketball is every two days
you can basically swing violently one
way to possibly
exactly the problem that Stephen is
gonna have if he doesn't check himself
because he has a huge voice in America
Donald Cerrone could literally just be
walking up to him on here and beat the
[__] out of them yeah like these aren't
like basketball players things they
fight in a cage for a reason so Joe
Rogan's very respectful because Rogen's
had his run-ins with Hogan's been
checked rogue and the fee time I
remember Rampage Jackson back in that
long time ago being like pissed off
because Rogan was critiquing him in just
on his leg kick defense to be fair
though to Joe what you do have to
acknowledge is when he did think he
pissed off a fighter he apologized he
but on camera as well which is quite
interesting yeah he knows he's dealing
with savages he's not dealing with
basketball players this guy with this
attitude is gonna be in serious problems
if he doesn't watch him satting probably
say yeah so Joe Joe takes him to task on
his podcast you call a guy a quitter
first of all he had a broken orbital
bone okay you saying he was a quitter he
got his face smashed yeah okay
he got cracked by one of the biggest
punchers in the sport he he has the most
wins in the sport he has the most wins
by finish he has the most bonuses I mean
come on
here's the most fights I chose right 100
samurais it's not like losing a
basketball game you've been humiliated
you've been beaten up by another man in
the cage and then you're getting
criticized by your man who's never made
the walk for us as fans making videos on
YouTube we could say what the [__] we
want Stephen here has a responsibility
you're not position he's also been even
pay so much money the main issue is the
more mainstream that UFC gets the more
of these bad hot takes you're probably
going to get around you and it's gonna
come to a point where if these men are
you know real men so hard all these kind
of things that something might happen
with a reporter or something like that
but when you hit the mainstream like you
know you have to be willing to take a
lot more of the rough with a lot more of
the smooth and the problem is for these
fighters who have been very protected in
a very niche community for quite a long
time they're about to come up to a wave
of people probably like me sir O'Neill's
[__] shirt or whatever man yeah we
don't know about that but that's fine
from fans
but when report I start doing it they're
gonna come up against the wave of wave
of badass mixed martial artists even in
his hip pocket him on Twitter
just to be clear this is a three minute
thirty video that he's made disguise the
main criticism of Steven ace was from
jørgen was you do not in your position
come out and call cowboy Cerrone ik
winner in this three and a half minutes
not once the Steven Naismith addressed
that point where at all and he just
skirts around it hot air I'm at the end
of this video I was literally like you
are a waste of space you you've seen
Steven Naismith before yeah like if
someone makes a criticism of you
addressing their respective Joe Rogan
but you're wrong on this one my man me
Stephen a Smith me being at the Conor
McGregor fight against Cowboys were only
saying what I said that he did show us
much at forty seconds not the point he
made nothing to do with Conor McGregor
the main point was you concourse aronia
quitter right this describes the ESPN
plus the level of attention there they
got the traffic that it generated and
digital and beyond check the numbers
number one I mean I you know what about
when people say I mean yeah well I think
your honor but the numbers Hebrew and
now I think he's just talking about a
ESPN numbers of course people are gonna
go and watch the fight it's the one of
the biggest fights of the year but
numbers what the [__] is that even a
vote I think there's not a relevant
point what he's saying he said Hodder
McGregor was fighting you [__] you
could have no commentary no analysis and
just sure McGregor turning or thank you
granny the same amount of people would
[__] watch I'd actually pay more for
them people are tuning and for him I pay
more just to say sit with not hungry
Rogen's biggest fun but everyone knows
why McGregor fight to does matter who
the hell's comment it yeah mute I have
been a reporter for 25 years I have
covered sports on a variety of
competitive levels regardless of what
the support is sports isn't fighting not
the same thing not to convince me that
Conor in a rematch in a rematch against
the mega medal that wouldn't cut it
literally not the point he made on the
night yeah isn't the point of our organs
disagree with him on real this is what
you're saying is that Steven Naismith
he's just changing the object even a
Smith goes all over the place please
this is no use is he by portlet he's all
over this job I've seen him of all kids
of it on boxing and stuff like he's
entertaining because he's just loud and
silly I think partly his colleagues
around him sometimes they like him he's
a nice guy and they tolerate his takes
because it also lets them take another
position sometimes it gets a
conversation going
I've gotta the problem is for Stephen a
he's coming into a space where there's
already a very good healthy conversation
hosted by people like Joe Rogan
elegant conversation yeah and this is
coming into a spore way out of his depth
he's being checked by the the by Yoda
yeah there's no no he's saying I'm like
just calm the [__] down with your hot
takes because we don't do that over here
we don't [__] on a legendary fighter
when we're in a position of commentary
we certainly don't just disregard who he
was and everything like that
and you got an awesome stuff as well you
actually have to know the sport now
apparently this discipler has been
making efforts to learn fighting yeah I
mean yeah do you want to say his his
hard work there he is Steve Naismith
lighting that was funny leave Joe Rogan
alone we've covered this guy before on
true news pretty pretty big I don't
really remember him I'm right about him
yeah my girlfriend
Alexia dies empowered paradise yeah
there you go okay now this is a guy who
sleeps in the sarcophagus in his room so
I'm not first of all sure whether we can
actually trust him but the other day he
cried about his girlfriend resting in
paradise I know when I'm stopping I'm
sorry
yeah oh you can tell this is [__]
from the jump yeah a lot of people are
very outraged by it though okay so I
know when I'm devastated I give every
detail about my secondhand Channel
what's up guys I just got off the phone
with Alexia's parents they had set up a
memorial on the side of the road for
Alexia unbelievable the level this guy
goes to like and imagine being this
desperate for views imagine not only
that but starting what you believe to be
a video mourning your girlfriend again
what's up guys genuinely thought there's
a lot of youtubers out there who'd do
[__] and I'm like yeah you see the video
anyway come on MIT boy I get it like
sometimes you just got to scrape the
barrel every youtuber every now and then
we'll do something like that I get it
but this is just like
how's he revealed that it was [__]
well I mean I think it reveals it's
[__] when two days sorry
yeah two days after that you're calling
the Tooth Fairy can I say either she's
dead or they're broken up and let's have
pitted me that kind of hope she is yeah
yeah cuz I'm like if this is what you
thought about her then she doesn't you
shouldn't have to survive with you
oh god absolutely should be better off
without you death is better than living
heavy yeah I've never boom I'm assumin
and you're never going heaven would be
bloody great unlock or ya know we'll
both be burning in hell for true news
and sadly you drag me here thing is
Brian there's kind of a spate of bad
acting on YouTube right now and it's
really beginning to piss me off
Dave taubira has been everywhere lately
yes good in there doing watching days no
brick he's really good
you had half of a sex tape yes how much
was it yes my think about Theodoric
great guy
clearly doing well for a reason good
Korea are well yeah but I think he gets
away with making the jokes that I would
make or whatever or saying crude [__]
cuz he's got that like boyish face like
if he had tattoos and all that revered
he people wouldn't like him as much I
think it's frustrating to me it's a I
see all that [__] keep telling yourself
that
yeah you know I buy me friends stuff if
I had all that money yeah you don't have
it me you bought yourself two cars in
succession I didn't get anything but
them anymore so yeah exactly
got your PlayStation what yeah same
thing I'm driving players those cars
yeah the element of reality in the
Tobruk videos odd non-existent now it's
just all [__] isn't it let's watch
as he sits in the car with Nicole
Scherzinger guys I'm here with Nicole
for the put here both much and Javed to
do a video with her just like it looks
like I CGI'd you into my video I'm not
gonna lie I couldn't like pull it like
just joke around with it yeah he's just
going
he's gonna have the biggest one after
you know the main problem that he'll
he'll be just dishing como you have to
put this on that's the point where you
put your penis in among a few moments
later I just keep thinking I wonder what
her butthole tastes like you might
remember Ben Brown just a few years ago
he was the big travel vlogger sort of
loved himself a little bit too much
Neverhood he was very woke traveled the
world so there's a lot of those on
youtubes or there's other guy Alfie
deyes mate with a long brown hair
I remember him on a little trip to
Africa I was banging on about should we
should we meet in that you mean fun for
Louie
oh yeah he was on a video Russell Brand
the other day yeah that's fun for Louis
fun for no-one else though so I know I
don't know if anyone's actually watching
it off of this guy's who just sort of no
one's of a check before we turn a penny
mate with any penny I'm in an open
relationship is what this video is
called
and it's 22 minutes long I'm in an open
relationship
and basically I'm single and I haven't
been single for this amount of time ever
that's the coronavirus psychedelic whoa
this is for the ones who know genuinely
this is the weirdest intro I've ever
seen on a youtube especially for him can
we go back completely the start again
yeah okay open relationship profound
ever straighten straighten Swan a
faithless is best song so did it did it
that that you know when jazz is being
serious deep show yeah this is the real
gents a little too serious but with a
bit more money yeah and a little more
self-satisfaction yeah
[Applause]
what is going on what the [__] he's
transitioning people don't really take
the series oh [__]
whoa bug goodbye I would already do that
when watching they're coming out the
back what no people don't really do this
and this check comes a place of love and
gratitude again if we start all over
welcome back I use the Skype appear his
own bills I don't believe anyone can be
this Zen you have to have no stress in
your life to act like this yeah I mean I
was very much like this before I met you
there's no way his dad isn't rich I'm
just saying it right now his dad is rich
sure there's no way you can act like
that I think it's important to remember
that you might as well as I have free
will to do whatever we feel like doing
at any given moment you can't just do
whatever you want whenever you want Paul
all right all [__] right Hitler I was in
a relationship with and we were together
for a year and a half and then a few
months ago she got sick of his [__] yeah
she took of ash a constant you can't
listen to this type of [__] and
enjoy it for longer than you know 18
months yeah especially if the dicks not
good absolutely the most incredible
profound nourishing who is this woman
what kind a woman it's not anyone a pass
of nourishment on she bringing you food
is up with your meaning women don't
bring this sort of guidance a
nourishment they don't they bring stress
annoyance frustration drama arguments
hosed mind let those emotions I mean you
know the message by now let those
emotions flow emotions are energy
emotion and if you don't let them do the
motion bit
energy just sits in you and then becomes
like a little emotional wound that you
carry it's Italy has the type of cotton
to goes to Africa to build houses so you
can tell every what he did it not
actually build the houses Judith I mean
yeah but I mean II did actually build
the houses so welfare doesn't matter why
than does yeah have you been to Africa
no no maybe you should find out a bit
more about in here not here or here so
this is actually the reason why I am
Heather and I consciously uncoupled
consciously uncoupled what a great way
to describe a break this guy's talk so
much I mean I think he's jealous
you should do yoga I guarantee already
of yoga who has four weeks in Bali why
didn't I get a Rich Dad you got a rich
you became rich and spent it I do meet
no abroad it ya know you've blown your
job cold water barley for four weeks and
upload [__] like this I've got to do
Barney's not expensive Brian bar news
Bali's in here not here I think that
this guy is really bothered about this
relation I think we should have no cake
off I think he's really bothered yeah
I've sort of let it go in there made a
22-minute video about it I sort of let
it go no but we consciously uncoupled
yes you know we just let our energy I
really feel like what he's trying to say
is we brought up mmm we didn't find
anyone else until something else comes
along our cell sugar
yeah yeah brilliant are we done yeah one
minute there you go pal that's a buddy
you could have BAM that's we cam the
true Jordi Channel toxic masculinity but
delivered in a woke way boom now Brian
something that relaxes you now I know
you love [__] and I know you love ASMR
these two are cats doing ASMR
someone has covered the ears of that in
tuna yeah that's really is that
triggering you rung yeah I don't like
licking so imagine you're is covered in
tuna with two cats just looking at what
radar no don't [__] with them rule 0 let
them lick your ears spend another buck
together oh yeah forgot about the
relaunch so for those who don't know the
beautiful people known as Spain and Alex
Spencer Alex spandex ah yeah
in 2019 confirming it along with this
girl into pregnancy and along with all
the [__] I had to be the worst da of
human history yeah it just made one feel
a bit twenty twenties off two Abajo it
started good because the back together
and they've announced it on Instagram
I'm delighted with this you can search
all of the land and the topic read the
romantic pit at the bottom says it in
football terms further but eventually
you realize there's nothing quite like
where you started yeah I'd like that
does I did read it and think I don't
really want to know about your searching
you know I want the romance yeah don't
want to hear about the London sees I
won't tell you what what were you
getting up do I wanted a 22-minute video
where he goes we were sort of you know
we were finding ourselves in that time
we consciously uncouple we consciously
uncoupled but she never forget to
hashtag it so thankfully she came she
stiff not even even after this were up
she was still like a team oh yeah you
know I mean he was always she is all the
time I as a youtuber this is the kind of
Queen men need oh here on YouTube
absolutely yeah she says delighted to
announce after a one-year loan deal
which makes me wonder waves Lord - I'll
see you from ISM in a way yeah we don't
want to know what you've been get into
the you from is meant to be happy I'm
returning to my boyhood club and ready
to sign a long-term contract lovely
insinuating that when they were kids
they fell in love he actually met in
their early twenties so we're really
happy for them
yeah it's good to see them back she's
being the one from day one we all knew
it yeah twenty-nine million views for a
breakup video hey guys I don't even know
how to do this intro
there's a lot of bubbles me and Nathan
no longer being together and Nathan and
Jeffrey what's wrong with us it doesn't
stink anymore of white privilege than
this yeah you know YouTube's just a
bunch of white privilege [__] isn't
it yeah we were actually in an open
relationship
Nathan and I we're sort of wondering if
we should break up
oh just [__] off no one gives a [__] get
back to making your makeup [__] one
Willy Wonka of [__] maker
1.5 million likes as a lot of people who
care though yeah
I'm not one of them
you know we're both in a state of shock
when you break up with someone how can
you be in a state of shock lor sure it's
be in common well you never know
sometimes it comes to shocking on one
side the other part is like yeah the
other part is going you didn't see this
train coming good luck but I've been
hanging on for a year here longer
probably I'm yeah with Jeffries or going
ah you go I think I'm gonna break up not
yours let's take a private jet to Vegas
and he goes to tomorrow night yeah yeah
it must be really hard when you're with
someone who's so loaded and you're like
should I break up cause like I've got a
good life here I went and up in a
massive pink bed and there's dog
[__] everywhere but we got clean I
was cleaning up after them I don't have
to do anything yeah what else happened
if I want something I've got it yeah all
you have to do do whatever Jeffries in
to keep them happy what do you reckon
well it may be sucking each other off
yeah gay men don't always whine one day
Geoffrey comes at the room and is like
throwing a bitch-fit
and he's just like you know what it is
I'm sick I can't do this anymore
and then Geoffrey's like this is apps
delayed shock oh my god yeah I just
can't believe what we're I'm aghast I'm
in shock I'm absolutely agar got you
anyway Jeff we hope you're all right if
you're that rich and you can't keep a
man hard oh good hard cuz I tell you
what as a man if the woman's got loads
of money or the other guys got loads of
money that's such a rare situation of
being in a man because because of the
way the world works men tend to be the
one with the money
the world's not fair but imagine budget
is being kept in that he's playing
PlayStation every day you know Jeffrey
Combs he's like you know let's go to
Vegas let's do the top of the private
jet he's like I'm playing rocket leek
and women share having a bit of a
private tete-a-tete yeah a little
wannabe something's been going on there
how we never know Shane's getting that
make up money now and he's like you know
what it is that's pretty [__] good
that Dawson dick imagining and it could
be like the new YouTube Queen and Queen
now Geo it's time for you to hit the
food reviewer I do reviews on the
youtubes you never knew such a cool dude
I keep it so flat and do you know why
it's because I know whether to buy there
oh when the Girl Scouts show up and they
set their table up inside and you
doesn't you look at it all day no like
oh my god Thin Mints are back nobody did
a video about ten minutes
like yes yeah he loves that this was
perfectly timed this is legit Wow move
the jack out of the way sure that double
chin boobies I love it I love him
another one
Wow looking awful just staring you down
awesome yeah I mean no no but like it
looks like chocolate I think it's sort
of like a minty biscuit with a bit of
chocolate is it looking after it was
biscuit I think so yes yes oh great it
the ideal yeah we make those up in
England we can make them happen we could
bring him over and you can make them for
us easily the best girls oh they are so
addicting get them now I've got to say
his last few videos of lack energy oh
yeah yeah that's a return of foam yeah I
mean we're back baby
and if we're your buck if we're talking
about a return to form then let's try
the impossible whopper
from Burger King make love to me just a
sudden a sudden change and he's wearing
a cowboy what is it about the hut that
make some of the bugs some [__]
Dustin hottest you know I love it is
this fake me oh [__]
eat it like a cowboy come on son oh I'm
really eager to hear what the [__] yes
to say about this I love this fake me
I've never tried I've got no interest in
tribe real mate if you know what I mean
there's a myths about vegetarian burgers
and vegetarian stuff and that it's
automatically good for you that's
[__] like that's the one thing that
is [__] like a lot of the stuff that
they put into these burgers to try and
get it to taste like meat or be like me
there's sacrificing in other ways in
order to get it like meat so it might
just be unhealthy [__] for you but it's
not me delivered on that but the
sacrifices are made elsewhere so I've
seen I also think this have [__] real
meat that's what the [__] yeah
oh that's a bad pickle just threw it in
the back of the car this guy is such a
bad boy he just took it off I definitely
you read the texture course he's right
monkeys the [__] food reviewer he
does reviews on the youtubes wrong I'm
still your tomcod compared to his Tom
Punk yeah it is that we're talking about
an expert this is Jorgen yeah and this
is Steven ear Smith yeah you shouldn't
even be talking him about food let him
get on with this and you asked his
opinion yeah I'm not sad and that's
probably all we got for today like a
funny the true news we finished with the
Great One himself food reviewer comet
it's fair to say today you know we
really to subscribe to him yeah we
always like to help him out he's
uploading regularly no support the guy
that was true news for seeing him next
week for more true news also get to
subscribe to us be sure to hugged your
loved ones tell them you love them
sure here another bright one when you
supposed to enjoy life while you can
namaste dear friends thank you very much
for sharing your time and choosing to
spend your time with us we love you guys
see you soon
okay bye bye alright